تشهد العاصمه العراقيه بغداد مسيره لنصره
الشعب الفلسطيني ولدعم عمليه طوفان الاقصى
خرجت بدعوه من ائتلاف الرافدين لنصره
الاقصى وانطلقت المسيره بعد صلاه الجمعه
من جامع البراق في منطقه الغزاليه ببغداد
باتجاه جامع ام القرى وهو احد اكبر مساجد
العاصمه حيث ندد المشاركون بالعدوان
الاسرائيلي على قطاع غزه وجرائم الاحتلال
بحق
الفلسطينيين
منطقه الغزاليه غربي بغداد معنا من هناك
مراسلنا عامر لافي عامر ايضا هذه المنطقه
تشهد تظاهرات حدثنا عن هذه التظاهرات ما
الذي ترفعه من
شعارات نعم سلمى نحن كما ذكرت في منطقه
الغزاليه في غرب بغداد هذه المنطقه الان
بدات بعد صلاه الجمعه من مسجد صاحب راق
وتحولت بعد ان كانت هناك بعض الكلمات
تحولت الى مسيره انطلقت نحو واحد من اكبر
مساجد العاصمه
بغداد وهو مسجد التابع لرئاسه ديوان الوقف
السني هنا هذه طبعا المظاهره هي مظاهره
اسبوعيه دعيني اقول لكنها في كل
اسبوع يتم اجراؤها في مكان مختلف في
العاصمه بغداد في كل جمعه هناك مظاهره
دعما ونصره لغزه وللتنديد
سالتي عن الهتافات التي نسمعها وعن
اللافتات التي رفعت في هذه المظاهره وفي
كل المظاهرات حقيقه التي نتابعها استنكار
وتنديد بالعجز العربي والعجز الاسلامي
وبالصمت الدولي هذه ربما من اكثر الشعارات
التي نسمعها في الهتافات حتى اتهام
بالتامر العالمي على غزه وشعب غزه
وبالتالي هناك الكثير من اللافتات
والهتافات التي تطالب حتى هنا في بغداد
بطرد السفير الامريكي والبريطاني
والالماني الاعتبار ان هذه الدول داعمه
ومتامن كما يقولون على الشعب الفلسطيني
كما ذكرت هذه
احدى اللافتات واحدى الهتافات التي ترفع
هنا في كل جمعه كما ذكرت ايضا هناك دعوات
واسعه سواء في هذه المظاهرات او خارج هذه
المظاهرات ل المطالبه بمقاطعه المنتجات
الامريكيه على اعتبار ان كما يقولون
امريكا هي الداعم الرئيسي لهذه الحرب التي
تخوضها اسرائيل ويقولون بانها يعني عباره
عن مجازر وليست حروب يتم فيها قتل الاطفال
وتدمير غزه بالكامل طبعا المظاهرات سلمى
هي احد اوجه الاعتراض والدعم الذي يقدمه
العراقيون لغزه لا ننسى طبعا بانه هناك
بشكل شبه يومي تقوم المقاومه العراقيه
ايضا بقصف القواعد الامريكيه في العراق
وفي سوريا ويوميا هناك تقريبا بيانات
تتحدث عن هذا القصف على سبيل المثال اليوم
صباح اليوم اعلنت المقاومه انها قصفت
قاعده عين الاسد في منطقه الانبار في غرب
العراق وبالتالي يعني اخر تصريح للولايه
المتحده من البنتاجون تقريبا كان قبل
حوالي خمسه ايام تحدث عن
151 هجوما استهدف القواعد الامريكيه سواء
في العراق او في سوريا ايضا المطالبه
باخراج قوات التحالف وعلى راسها القوات
الامريكيه من داخل العراق على اعتبار كما
ذكرنا بانهم ينظرون الى الولايات المتحده
على انها الداعم الرئيسي ولولا دعم
الولايات المتحده لما استمرت هذه الحرب
الحرب كما يقول يصفون هنا حقيقه في هذه
المظاهره بانها همجيه وعباره عن ارتكاب
مجازر بحق اهلهم في غزه هناك طبعا لافتات
كثيره ايضا رفعت لا اراها الان ولكن هناك
كان
ءهء الين سق غزه خل الحرب منبع من اكتوبر
ويقولون بانها هذه ليست ارقام وليست فقط
اسماء وانما هذه ارواح وامال
واحلام الكثير من الناس الذين كانوا
يعيشون في غزه ولم تلقي لهم الاله
العسكريه الاسرائيليه بالا وقتلتهم بدم
بارد فارادوا ان يوثقوا هذه الاسماء تكون
شاهدا على العالم وعلى ما يصفونه بالصمت
الدولي شكرا لك عامر اللافي وانو